Encuentra la pendiente de la línea
mostrada en la gráfica.
Repasando muy brevemente, la pendiente simplemente nos está diciendo que tanto está inclinada la línea recta.
El mejor modo de describirlo es, pendiente
es igual al cambio en "y",
el cambio en la coordenada "y" dividido entre el cambio en la coordenada "x"... cambio en "x".
Y para una línea recta, este valor siempre
nos da una constante,
aveces la escribimos con este pequeño triangulito que significa "cambio en".
Es una letra griega delta mayúscula y es
cambio en "y" entre cambio en "x".
Así que veamos cual es el cambio de "y" que
le corresponde a algún cambio en "x".
Y vamos a considerar ahorita puntos, que sean
muy sencillos de ubicar en esta gráfica.
Así que empecemos por acá...
mejor con otro color...
Empezamos en este punto y queremos ir a otro
punto que sea fácil de ubicar,
digamos a este punto de aquí.
Y podríamos haber en realidad elegido cualesquiera
dos puntos que quisiéramos en esta gráfica,
pero bueno...
¿Cuál es el cambio en "y", respecto al cambio en "x"?
Empecemos con el cambio en "x", así que en
realidad, en "x" nos movimos de aquí a acá
y mi cambio en "x" entonces es de 1 unidad,
2 unidades, 3 unidades,
así que el cambio en "x" vale 3.
Y, también lo podríamos ver desde las coordenadas.
Me moví desde la coordenada -3,
hasta la coordenada 0,
así que mi cambio en "x" es de 3 unidades positivas.
Mi delta de "x" es 3.
¿Y cuál es mi cambió en "y"?
Pues mi cambio en "y" es de -3 hasta -1,
o sea que es de 2, pero vamos a hacerlo de este modo.
Mi cambio en "y" es de 1 unidad, 2 unidades,
entonces es 2 unidades positivas.
Así que, ¿cuál es mi cambio en "y",
entre mi cambio en "x"?
Pues cuando mi cambio en "x" fue de 3, mi
cambio de "y" fue de 2 y esto es precisamente
la pendiente y como les dije, podía haber
elegido cualesquiera dos puntos sobre esta
recta y siempre obtendría el mismo valor.
Digamos, empecemos de nuevo.
Y ahora voy a elegir otros dos puntos e incluso
voy a ir en otra dirección.
Supongamos que ahora empiezo acá.
Y ahora me muevo hasta este punto de aquí.
Y vamos ahora a pensar en el cambio en "y".
¿Cuál es mi cambio en "y"?
Empecé aquí y me moví hacia abajo,
¿cuántas unidades?
Me moví, 1, 2, 3, 4 unidades.
Así que mi cambio en "y" es de -4.
Porque empecé en el 1 y baje
hasta la coordenada -3 en las "y".
Así que mi cambio en "y" es igual a -4.
¿Y cuál es mi cambio en "x"?
Pues empecé en este lugar de la "x" y me
moví todo este camino hacia la izquierda,
así que el cambio es negativo y me moví,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 unidades.
Así que mi cambio en "x" es de -6, porque
me moví a la izquierda,
así que mi delta "x" es -6, porque empecé en "x" igual a 3
y me moví a hasta "x" igual a -3,
así que el cambio total es de -6, recuerden
que me moví a la izquierda.
Así que, ¿cuánto vale mi cambio en "y"
entre mi cambio en "x"?
Pues es igual a -4, entre -6 y los menos se
cancelan y lo que me queda es 2 entre 3.
Así que obtengo el mismo valor,
solo hay que ser consistentes.
Aquí empecé y bajé 4 y después retrocedí
6, así que es -4 entre -6,
si ahora considero que empiezo en este punto de acá abajo, entonces primero subo 4,
así que mi cambio en "y" es de 4 y después mi cambio en "x" es de 6, porque avance,
así que de nuevo tengo mi cambio en "y" entre mi cambio en "x" es 4 entre 6, que es 2/3.
Así que no importa donde empiecen, solo hay
que ser consistente con las direcciones
y nos dará el mismo valor.